you've probably heard by now that the
latest Fantastic Four film was well a
bit of a disaster not only was it a
critical failure but it marked the
lowest box office debut for a Marvel
property since the sequel of Ghost Rider
in honor of Fantastic Four his five
other superhero movies that just plain
sucked
although now it's been saved by Netflix
the 2003 daredevil film starring Ben
Affleck was completely terrible luckily
for him though that movie doesn't
feature on this list because it's
spin-off Elektra what's worse Jennifer
Garner is known for kicking ass in less
than appropriate outfits
thanks to alias but nothing worst in
2005 Elektra the film had silly dialogue
and its plot shoehorned a love story
instead of focusing on what a
spectacularly cool chick Elektra is
gaana does her best with the role that
the tedious script was no friend to fans
of the character or pain movie going
still a totally viable Halloween costume
option though the early spider-man films
are considered to be pretty good
examples of superhero movies gone right
unfortunately the third time was not the
charm when it came to spider-man 3
director Sam Raimi has done some great
stuff in his time including the Evil
Dead and one of my personal favorite
shows Xena
he's also done some not-so-good stuff
and spider-man 3 falls into that
category
while his direction made spider-man 1 &
2 pretty great it's suspected that
number 3 suffered from execs pressuring
Raimi
to make fool calls like making
fan-favorite character venom half-baked
and having the alien symbiote possessing
Peter Parker way too frequently the main
issue with the film is that it paints
Peter Parker as a real egocentric asshat
who sort of makes you want to root for
the villains
fortunately that's easy because the
movie is overloaded with villains
seriously it's like a Rocksteady Batman
game in there most of the movies on this
list cropped up over the last decade but
the Batman of Robin films featuring the
other wives talented George Clooney is
an absolutely classic in the field of
crappy superior movies it may have been
a good while since the movie's debut in
1997 but clearly still repeatedly
apologizes for the film that thought it
was far more clever and funny than it
actually was
after Tim Burton killed it with Batman
and Batman Returns director Joel
Schumacher killed
in a whole other way with Batman Forever
and Batman and Robin with Batman and
Robin Schumacher wanted to pay homage to
the kam penis of the 1960's Adam West TV
series but it just came off as a way to
over-the-top both the plot and
characters will ludacris there were too
many rubber bat nipples for mr. freeze
puns were painful and Schumacher himself
has also apologized for the film since
best to skip this one and give the Dark
Knight to rewatch while I love a good
comic book hair when they certainly have
featured in some not so great films
although none were quite as bad as Halle
Berry's Catwoman if you're after Halle
Berry portraying an amazing superhero
you're better off watching her play
storm in the x-men series because
Catwoman is just not worth the trouble
much like a lecture the storyline seems
to avoid everything interesting about
cat woman's character and backstory in
favor of highlighting only the top
action sequences and horrendous acting
fast if the filmmakers put a little less
time into costume design and a little
more into plot and character development
this might be watchable as it is the
film grabbed itself for infamous Golden
Raspberry Awards the worst picture worst
actress worst director and worst
screenplay Halle Berry accepted her
award in person and apologized for the
catastrophe
I don't usually rank things all that
strictly in these list shows but I can
say that this is the worst superhero
movie I've personally thought all the
way through it's the ludicrously stupid
green lanten thank god kostas Ryan
Reynolds and Blake Lively decided to get
hitched off to this film because that is
literally the only good thing that came
out of it even with the usually
hilarious Reynolds betraying Hal Jordan
this movie stunk under a horrible clunky
script and reliance on really crappy CGI
the film fell way short of the 500
million it needed to score a profit
making just 220 million at the box
office the part was overly complicated
and punctuated with one of the least
compelling love stories to feature in a
McCarron maybe although as I said
ironically resulting in a real-life
marriage
luckily for Ryan Reynolds he's getting
another run at it with the upcoming
Deadpool movie which looks pretty damn
fantastic there are so many awful
superhero movies that I haven't had time
to mention here so be sure to let me
know what tops you are listed down in
that comment section I will catch you
again soon